يمكنني مدير مصنع لانتاج الملابس في موسكو
لم يواجه ازمه في التسويق منذ انطلاق ما
سمتها موسكو بالعمليه العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
ادوات الانتاج وبعض المستلزمات بسبب مشاكل
النقل منذ اسابيع بدانا نتجاوز هذه
المشكله ما يساعدنا ان خاماتنا من السوق
المحليه
يعتمد على الاسواق الداخليه لم يتاثر لكن
العديد من دور الازياء في روسيا فقدت
عقودها الخارجيه وعانت من مشاكل التحويلات
البنكيه
نقود وتصدير منتجاتنا للخارج توقفت بسبب
صعوبات النقل والتحويل البنكي صناعه
النسيج وصناعه الحاويات وغيرها واجهت
مخاطر انهيار بسبب توقف استيراد مستلزمات
الانتاج وانهارت خطه روسيا في ان تصبح
اكبر مركز لانتاج السيارات في اوروبا بعد
تراجع حجم انتاج السيارات اكثر من 75%
وخروج الشركات الاجنبيه التي افت مصانع في
روسيا من اسواقها الخبراء والروس يرون ان
الجانب الاخطر هو الحصار الغربي على قطاع
الطاقه الروسي
العقوبات التي فرضت ادت الى تقليص صادرات
النفط والتاثير على اسعارها وتسببت في
انخفاض عائدات الخزينه الحكوميه وبالتالي
نتج عجز في الموازنه
نسب عجز ميزانيه الحكومه في السنوات
السابقه وصلت الى خمسه بالمئه لكنها
تجاوزت هذا الرقم بعد العقوبات نتيجه تقلص
صادرات النفط الروسي اكثر من 30% وزياده
النفقات الحكوميه الى نحو 50%
الحكومه منعت انهيار الروبل بايقاف
تداولات العملات في البلاد والزام
المصدرين بتحويل ما يحصلون عليه كعائدات
من عقودهم الخارجيه الى الروبل ادى هذا
الاختلال في اسعار العملات لكن هذا
التوازن تتم استعادته حاليا
يتوقع خبراء روسيا يستمر انخفاض واردات
روسيا من الخارج اكثر من 30 % وانخفاض حجم
صادرتها ايضا رغم الجهود المكثفه التي
تبذلها الحكومه لزياده حجم التجاره مع
الهند وتركيا والبرازيل بعد زياده حجم
التجاره مع بلدان رابطه الدول المستقله